one thing is simply the use of language
if English is not your first language or
you tend to write awkwardly sometimes
you think you're not a good writer
because your word choice is bad but
that's one skill that you can work on
like literally like a dictionary skill
like choosing great vocabulary and
choosing great imagery right that's one
skill second skill is taking a character
through a journey it's actually
understanding the psychology of people
and understanding if I'm I think I'm
ugly how do I walk through the world how
does a character overcome the belief
that I'm ugly right and that's actually
an understanding of people and
understanding of psychology and you want
to let know that so you can create
characters that are deep and interesting
and you want to be a great observer of
your friends of your parents of your of
all the people who annoy you right so
that you can document document who they
are but also understand them from an
interesting perspective that's a
different skill then there's another
skill which is especially for filmmaking
is being able to show not tell being
able to ground all of your scenes in
moments that are visual that extent that
give all the information you want to
give but don't don't have it me tell you
and then this happened and then this
happened and then this happened and then
this happened right and the last one
which is probably the most important one
and very difficult for people to do is
to really speak from your authentic
voice and we we we want so much as
writers to be seen and to be heard and
we know that we have something to say
and that desire that longing can pull us
out of ourselves
and and when you get pulled out of
yourself
then you're trying to imitate Breaking
Bad you're trying to imitate scandal
you're trying to imitate some movie that
you love and you've lost your sense of
what it is you're bringing to the world
what you've seen in the world so finding
that authentic voice and saying what I
know is valuable what I see is valuable
the way I'm going to show it is valuable
is a skill in itself and it's the
practice of actually affirming your
unique vision like being able to go into
a Starbucks even and saying the way I
order my Starbucks the way I like my
Maya pasta the way I like to cross the
street the way I like to drive is unique
and valuable and the more you anchor
into the sense of your own value and the
importance of your voice in the world
the more powerful that voice is going to
be because the other things I describe
are literally like techniques that you
can practice but this other technique of
actually affirming your own authentic
voice is probably the most important one
yeah the first step is what turns you on
that's always what it is you should
never write to the market the market
will always horrify you right now it's
selling our superhero stories to the
studios but if you don't like writing
superhero stories you shouldn't say oh
well I'm going to write one anyway
because you'll fail you have to write
from passion and my experience yes even
writers who are professionals you write
from what you love and you write from
what embarrasses you and you write from
your core wounds we all have things that
we love to talk about and those come
from our core wounds and I say every
storyteller is wounded and they're tying
to tell a story to heal that wound we
all have a dozen core wounds
I'm ugly my mother didn't love me I'm
badly socialized no one understands me I
go to a party I can't talk me but no one
will listen to me I'm lonely I'm alone I
can't reach out I'm married but I'm I'm
not happy because I really can't be
myself there's all these wounds we all
have and we carry them inside ourselves
that's really what we're always writing
about always and this is true for unthe
era PI's writers who are very successful
even if they never looked at a
psychologist couch and they laugh at
this when I work with them turns out
what they're writing about always is
their core wound so ask yourself as a
storyteller
why don't what I'm interested in what
are the movies I love I guarantee you
when you do that you'll find out that is
your place where you need to start are
you interested in love now I'm
interested in computers well then you
might want to write a sci-fi movie
because you're sort of mechana sized and
that's your that's your bliss but I
guarantee you that comes from a core one
too so you must start with what excites
you and then shaping it is just a matter
of after you've done a passion draft
what I call just a draft of whatever you
want your story to be about it could be
a paragraph it could be a line it could
be 50 pages then it's time to think
about I don't want to shape this because
the shape is always going to be the same
if it's a movie or a television show the
shape will always be the same and
learning what that shape is is your job
as a screenwriter is your job as a
television writer but it must have come
from your passion the best questions a
screenwriter can ask themselves to make
the story better one thing is is how is
this my story how is whatever this story
is how does it relate to me so that I
can use my emotions to go to tell this
story better because what the weirdest
part about being a screenwriter is that
we sit in a room alone we are isolated
from society
we basically are cut off from emotional
situations we hate conflict we hate all
of these things that then we're going to
use those are the elements we need to
use to make our story passionate and and
emotional and all of those things so all
the things that we sort of fear to deal
with we now have to deal with and so
basically look at the story one of the
things with assignments that I have to
find a doorway into an assignment so if
I am offered a deal I'm offered some
thing that I read a book whatever some
assignment where they're going to hire
you to write the script I have to look
at that and go how is this story my
story so I can tell it honestly because
if it has nothing to do with me
then I'm just taking money and typing
and the bad part about that is the
script will not work the worst part
about it is then you may have to do it a
couple of rewrites after that on a
script that becomes torture it's like
I'm just typing this I'm just writing it
I have no connection to the story so
then it becomes work and you know if any
of us you know wanted to be wanted to do
work we wouldn't be writers so even if
the story is not exactly similar notably
there's me yeah exactly that's me some
thing in there that that's that I can
relate to if I don't relate to the story
then it's like I don't get this so it's
like I can I had a meeting with the
people that did that did the Tom Clancy
Jeff Ryan movies at once and I can
totally relate to Jack Ryan even though
I've never been in the Navy you know
down the line but it's like I am a guy
that that is the bookworm who knows
things but doesn't necessarily know how
that isn't the action guy so that's the
way that I can get into that story and I
think if you look at the you know
Harrison Ford Jack Ryan movies and the
Baldwin Jack Ryan movies those really
have the guy who's the fish-out-of-water
is the the Brainiac who now has to do
action stuff where the problem with the
reboot version was he was the
action guy who had to do action stuff it
doesn't work you know it didn't work as
a movie but that would if I were offered
that I would say I can't do that story
I'm not I can't relate to that character
I can relate to other characters but I'm
not sure I can relate to that character
so you kind of look at things and go
where's what's my doorway into this
story and it could be something where
it's symbolic it could be something
where you know if I'm trying to think of
some example now and I can't off the top
of my head but the okay that the
weirdest part about assignments is that
you end up being offered things you go
that's a movie so somebody offers you
Lego the motion picture and you
immediately go there is no story there
but if you find the story in there and
you go okay I'm going to do a story
about a rebel in a world where
everything is awesome I am a rebellious
type person so I can see that story so
you you find your story in there and
sometimes you look in the material and
your story isn't there you know there's
there's there's things you will be
offered that you go I could hack that
out and make money but it would be hack
work so I always try to turn those down
and try to wait for somebody to offer me
the job where I go I want to do this
project have to meet the hero have to
show the hero living his or her everyday
life before anything extraordinary
occurs that's going to move the story
forward you can have something
extraordinary if it's part of that
characters everyday life but it can't be
the thing that is going to get the hero
moving toward the climax yet it's static
in a certain way it's the everyday life
and the other must have is you must
create empathy with that character we've
got to connect with that character
psychologically now to me the key ways a
writer would do that is you either get
us to feel sorry for the character make
the make the character the victim of
some undeserved misfortune
so in Avatar at the beginning we find
out that he's been crippled in the war
and he's just lost his brother who was
killed and that's why he's there taking
his place so all of that is designed
to immediately get us to sympathize with
this character and that creates this
empathy or psychological connection
another way is to create jeopardy for
the character put their life in danger
if it's an action movie put their job or
their love life in danger anything
that's of importance to them because we
identify with characters we worry about
and the third way is you make them a
nice person good-hearted generous kind
show them as well-liked by other
characters so you have to have at least
one or two of those as you introduce the
hero so that your audience or your
reader will actually become that
character psychologically and that's
what you're going for to me movies are
participatory they aren't something we
observe there's something we step into
so in Titanic were the ones on the
sinking ship we're the ones falling in
love with Leo DiCaprio or whatever
because you establish this empathy those
to me are the essentials that's good
what we care about is to see a character
overcome a deep weakness now the
audience thinks that the story is all
about the hero achieving his goal right
because then we've got success and
that's important and in most stories the
hero will accomplish his goal by the end
of the story but that is not what the
audience is most interested in they
can't tell you this but we know from
lots of experience hundreds of years of
storytelling that the cave the real fact
is not does the hero accomplish the goal
but does the hero overcome the great
weakness because that's what makes us
care about that character we see them in
pain we see them in trouble right if
they're already successful if they're
already a good and in some cases a
perfect person where where do they go
right there's nothing for them to
overcome so that's why it's so important
that we show in the very opening pages
of ours
the great internal weakness of our
character now we may also want to give
them qualities that are likable
qualities that the audience can also
hook on to but those are not nearly as
important as establishing the weakness
upfront in the story one of the things
that I think is important is to know why
your villain is right and why your hero
is wrong or protagonist and antagonist
because often what happens is people
don't know why their protagonist is
wrong their protagonist is 100% right or
why their antagonist is right you know
is is on the right track and people are
multi-dimensional you know we're not all
good and bad so to find the good in the
bad character in the bad and the good
character are critical to making that a
three-dimensional character and that's a
tough thing for a lot of new writers is
they just want to have their their hero
wants to be there it's it's a as a
projection of themselves they're the
perfect version of themselves the
problem is a perfect person is dull we
like flawed people you know we want my
the example that I always use is liar
liar because Jim Carrey's character is a
bad father and says so and he is a
terrible father now he means to be a
good father but he's not so that
character flaw being the guy that I mean
his biggest character flaw is he
believes that a lie is better than the
truth so he lies to everybody so as to
not hurt their feelings and instead
hurts their feelings twice as bad when
they find out that it's a lie but he is
a character that's not a hundred percent
perfect he's a bad father and his
journey from bad father to good father
is what the story's about and often what
happens is new writers don't want to
have that journey they want to have the
character be a good father all the way
through because I'm a good person
this character is kind of part of me and
so they're going to be always good and
they don't want to explore the bad part
of themselves and we all have those
where none of us are perfect people we
all are flawed so you need to sort of
get dig into yourself often and find the
bad
parts of you and deal with those you
know on screen I did I already say
you're basically doing you're taking the
the things you wouldn't tell your best
friend and telling you know a hundred
million people worldwide that's part of
that one of the things about structure
that I found that sort of changed more
than anything for me because I didn't
realize this for the first ten or
fifteen years that I was a consultant
and lecturer and that is I always
thought a plot structure I mean it was
the sequence of events and the things
that happened and that's sort of
externally so this need and it is it is
a plot structure and there are certain
key things that need to happen at 25%
and 50% in 75 but the revelation to me
was when I realized that the inner
journey the character takes also has a
structure and it's exactly the same
structure the same six stages apply to
that and that intertwining of that outer
journey and inner journey as I said
before that to me is where it gets both
fascinating and really helpful to
writers because they can really
integrate those two things what's good
it was ability I'm saying that that
there are no bad I there the good news
is there are no bad ideas why is that
good news because well I can't have a
bad idea the bad news is it doesn't
matter it's not about ideas this is not
about ideas ideas are not important in
dramatic narratives that's a mouthful to
say and gets me a lot of criticism I was
at them a scholarly conference I was
telling you that I rarely go to
scholarly conferences I go to a lot of
writers conferences but it was in an
academic scholarly conference and
someone said at a writing panel this was
out of town this was up in Montana he
said you know the problem with your
program at UCLA I really wanted to hear
the rest of this is that we encourage
writers to write screenplays that are
get ready now because I've memorized
this too deeply encoded into the
dominant narrative mode I'll say it
again we encourage writers to write
scream those are the two
deeply encoded into the dominant
narrative modes I thought to myself what
and then I realized narrative is usually
what they say when they mean story I
heard myself say to him
because I was very kooky I said you mean
story and he said yes yes and I said to
him guilty you're right that's us we we
a story hardliners we think it's all
about story he said what we should be
doing is is inculcating into new writers
the the respect for the value of ideas
sounds great doesn't it but I was saying
[Music]
well I'm so sorry but we think ideas are
worthless and useless again it doesn't
go over very well but it's the truth any
real writer who's a serious writer has
any kind of successful will tell you
it's not about the idea and sometimes
when they say oh I got a great idea and
they they really believe that it is a
great idea it's not just an idea in fact
it's a story that's all work now for
example with King's Speech it's not just
a guy who stutters and hires a speech
therapist it's the King of England its
World War two you know what all of this
as we start to describe it it's no
longer just the idea now you're telling
this story I'm going to say it again
it's so obvious it's that it's hard to
see sometimes things are so obvious you
just can't see them and again here it is
it's all about story that's all it's
about it's about telling a good story
often people they're afraid to create
the conflict because the conflict gets
into the messy stuff and so they hold
back on the conflict when we need to get
into that conflict they there's a thing
that another another screenwriting
problem is delaying things because we
you know will that conflict really can't
happen until this point or at this point
sorry camera this point in the movie
when we're at this point
well what usually happens is they they
stall until they get to that conflict
when instead what they should do is have
that conflict happen here and then have
things just continue to get
worse so--that's seen here instead of
being the you know the the beginning of
the conflict instead is when the
conflicts a hell of a lot worse
they don't escalate their conflict
enough an escalating conflict is
important again it's an in dialogue it
would seem false if that character
didn't say there's a problem and here's
what it is or you know I have an issue
with you and they need to have that
issue it needs to be it needs to start
here
you know the fuse needs to not just be
lit but then it needs to explode and
that explosion has to start a chain
reaction of other explosions so that's
like an act to problem often is writers
try to not try to hold everything off
until act two when you need to kick off
with you know with something exciting
happening a lot of people think you
think the thing up in your head and then
you write it down but he says the
writing down of it is sort of the
thinking of it that there's a nexus
between the pen or the keyboard the
hands on the keyboard that kind of
create and you just never know and you
have to live with that uncertainty you
have to sort of rejoice in and celebrate
and embrace that uncertainty instead of
trying to eliminate the uncertainty I
think it all happens sort of organically
and it does take a long time you know I
think you know you just there's little
ideas percolating around all the time
and you think okay well maybe that could
be interesting and you start writing
some stuff and developing and sometimes
you find you flush it out is just not
that it's not going to engage you for a
film and sometimes you just find this
little germ of an idea you know and it
can just be you know a single thought or
a little you know some little thing you
know or a parson or whatever and one
little thing and then it starts to just
like pull things together you know you
start to see the resonances of different
things I really love that approach to
writing a screenplay you know that it's
really it's an act of curiosity and
discovery I feel like when you write a
screenplay it's like being an
archaeologist you're excavating
something that already exists somehow
and I think that sort of organic path
for me is definitely the way the Bears
the most fruit when I tried to be clever
or try to do it in a more strategic way
I think
the results are less interesting but
when it just comes you know my second
film is about a yoga teacher who is
meets her biological sister for the
first time absolutely
houses for the first time as an adult
and her half sister's a sex worker I
mean for me like this came partly like I
was working in a I was doing some
volunteering in a homeless shelter and I
talked to this woman and it was and she
told me the story in it you know it was
just something about her and this story
about being rescued the really read you
know just like it got me you know and I
started think about just people from
different walks of life and for me I've
worked as a yoga teacher and I actually
taught in a social welfare Center for
prostitutes for a while and that had
really made an impression on me and I
thought about I mean a lot about those
women and the violence with which they
lived and you know how does someone help
them and you know it's when you start
like just pulling things together that
you're interested in and it starts to
make its own shape and I feel like you
can't force that phase it's sort of like
having a baby it just grows by itself in
your belly for quite a long time before
you give birth and I think writing a
screenplay is like that you know you
have to allow yourself that gestation
period you know where you're just you
know letting things percolate and
letting yourself like just wander and
letting yourself be open to what might
be around the corner that could be the
thing that you know they explained
something I feel like it's a you know
it's just it's a journey you know
writing a screenplay
it's a journey you're discovering this
thing and you just want to be really
open to what it could be and and enjoy
it certainly doing absolutely also
having in a really organic way I had
certain ideas but then when we went out
to the desert it was sort of like oh it
just suddenly made sense this is a road
movie you know it's a road movie about
two people going to this place that's
really what the earth is going to look
like in the future you know and they're
obsessed with that and I feel like as a
screenwriter I often see this kind of
advice to screenwriters which go
something like you know read the trades
and and see what's selling and
you know and then write something like
that and study other screenplays and I
think good God you know I mean I think
reading a lot of books is very important
I think reading watching tons of movies
is super important reading some
screenplay so you understand the format
in the craft but then like allowing
yourself the space to really go off the
reservation you know and just allowing
it to form in its own way because the
first draft is really I mean it's just
the start of a very long journey you're
going to rewrite your script at least 20
times before you shoot you know I I
don't I've never heard of anyone that
does less than probably 20 drafts from a
first grade shooting script you know if
they do I'd love to meet them but I
think most people is it's like it's you
know it's a process you know and your
first draft you just want to make
yourself as free as you can and as
honest as you can and as curious as you
can and let things unfold and that will
I think that gives you the best chance
of writing something that's going to be
you know engaging and unique well before
I write anything I just think about it a
ton and I and I really make sure that I
feel like I have the arc of the story
and the characters and I know where
things are going
roughly but you know once I have that
and I decide that I'm going to take the
time and write this thing the first
seven days honestly are just writing
feverishly in a row without ever looking
back so that I don't have a chance to
destroy the idea before it has a chance
to live that's really what it's about I
mean I do have a thing when I'm writing
a first draft where I generally say I
write four to five pages a day once I
once I start to write the script
you know like four I'll let myself have
months of just like pulling things
together he'll know and I'm always
buying books that are connected to
whatever it is and marching films you
know just like just filling up all the
well in a sense and then I reach a
certain point where I'm like I'm ready
to write the script you know and and
then I'm totally strict about just you
know I'll set myself like four pages a
day or five pages day and that is it
like there's no excuse you know if it
takes you all day takes all day if it
takes an hour it takes an hour but
that's the minimum you're going to write
every day then I get the script done
that way and you know I think like when
you're
in that poses like somewhere usually
before you actually start writing a
script he's just not like it's just if
it's if it's not that interesting you to
you the resonances aren't if you're
having to force it you know at this
stage then I feel like abandon it a bit
JumpShip no because at that stage of
gestation and leading up to writing your
first draft if it's not holding you then
it's it's not gonna hold you you know
and maybe it'll come to you later you
know I have had that experience and I
think actually my second film is it was
a little like that so I think it had the
idea of Park I've had it for years
percolating you know the idea of a yoga
teacher and a sex worker then this
relationship between them you know and
so something but I couldn't really find
it I couldn't really crack it before and
then suddenly it was like oh yeah I get
it they're sisters you know and
different things you know came into that
so you know I think sometimes if you do
have a good idea but it's not quite
working out you're having to force it
you're pushing through it you know
sometimes the best thing is just to
leave it set it aside working something
else and then maybe it's a year later
two years later three years later you
come back to you go now I know what that
needs you know and and it can go again
that's really hard to say because it
take it's over the course of many months
you know so I I think there there's a
point where there are enough notes down
on page and you you understand your
story enough where it's time to start
writing those pages so I might write a
page he'll write a page we'll start
sharing them I know that we used uh for
both films I think we used Google Drive
and we were sharing a lot that way you
know we also go about it where we
eventually get to a point where we we
have the post-its on the wall and that
that that's when you when you actually
can get a film or your idea your you
know your script up on the wall in like
with hundreds of post-its and it makes
sense from beginning to end I think
that's when we decide to start assigning
each other
pages and scenes so we'll see okay you
look at that scene I think I got a
handle on that scene I'll take that can
you take that one because I don't have a
handle on that one and then we share
them and then we start to compile this
thing and that's how that's that's how
that's done I think the best part of
writing a script is when you actually
you've actually written enough of the
beginning the middle and the end that
you have visualized the whole entire
puzzle in a certain way so now you're
just along for the ride and it's not
it's not like painful and hard and
trying to figure anything out
you've figured it out now it's just like
I'm going to sit down and write this
scene or I'm going to put that scene I'm
going to put this scene here I'm gonna
put this scene here because I think of
screenwriting like a puzzle I very
rarely write in chronicle chronological
order I will literally write a scene
that I know is going to be in the movie
I might write the ending I mean I
literally and then I'll start moving on
oh no the scene goes here the scene goes
here no some people do that with index
cards like they'll write put put the
thing together with index cards I just
do it in the script I just cut and paste
and put that scene there and I'll like
write a scene and then just go more more
more knowing that I'm going to write
more scenes there but knowing that I
need to write that scene so I think once
you have actually I guess it's a
confidence thing once you're confident
that you know the story and the
characters and they're going to you know
it's like hey I can see Vegas we're
going to get there it's right there you
see the lights and everything I'm in
Barstow
all right everybody's right that's like
the most exciting part there's a little
bittersweet thing it's great to finish
like yes of course you love to finish
but a little bittersweet thing to
finishing it's sort of like finishing a
good book you're like oh my god it's
over I know what am I gonna do is there
more than oh it's over
like it's done so there's a little bit
of something that you know and I think
people feel that when they read a really
good book and they're just like wow do I
I'm not going to see those characters
again and how is amazing and but it's
done there are things you're supposed to
do as a writer that you should do you
should make outlines make your character
break down so all these things that you
like do you make your cards you plot out
your story or first and second third
I'll do any of that none of it
that's the perfect screenwriter yeah
that's when it has the folded sock
drawer yes that's the guy does it all
correctly I don't do any of it I like to
sit and think about the idea and then I
like to think about the character who
that woman or man is and what they're
like and what their world looks like and
then I just start to think about what
the movie might look like in my head and
once I sort of start seeing the movie
itself in my head then I start writing
it I don't know how it's going to end
necessarily unless it's a thriller if
it's a thriller I need to know how it's
going to end so I can know where I gotta
go if that makes sense you know because
you always want to have that ending that
could go so you think of the ending
first like what would be a cool oh and
then okay now how do I get there so I go
backward if it's a thriller if it's not
a thriller if it's just a story about
people in life in love or whatever it is
then I don't really think that much
about what's going to happen I just sort
of think about the people and where they
are and where I want them to be what the
world's like what they enjoy there's
usually a lot of wine involved because I
enjoy some wine and what happens is I
end up writing I think something that's
much more organic and much more
Here I am a writer and I can't find a
word what is the word organic and what
is it what's what's the word when
something just spontaneous Monday's
organic I end up writing something
that's more organic and spontaneous
because I haven't sort of telegraphed it
and kind of like it when you're acting
you know you always hear don't play
result you know because you've read the
entire script so your character is on a
journey so you know what that journey is
but the character doesn't know so you
don't want to play like you know what's
coming because you'll telegraph it to
the audience I find the same thing works
for me as a writer by not knowing
everything when I'm writing I'm
discovering it as I'm writing and it
makes the writing process exciting for
me because I'm like sitting there at the
keyboard I'm like this is great you know
you like what's going to happen next I
don't know I can't wait find out either
you know what I mean it's like it's a
spontaneous thing and then hopefully the
training and the laws of inevitability
that I try to keep focused in my head
you know kick in as I'm writing and when
it's done it's it's a really great it's
a really great story but yeah I I like
to look at it as a living breathing
story that's unfolding as if I'm
watching it and that drives me toward
the end because I feel like if I do all
the outline stuff for me if I do all the
outline stuff I've already kind of done
it already
so now it's like ah I gotta write at all
hey Ted all that I already figured it
out so I just like jump in start writing
how to improve a scene that you're
working on the first thing before you
even start writing the words of the
scene you want to step back and as usual
my suggested vices asked questions in
other words first of all you should have
already asked the questions who is my
hero
what is the hero's wound what are they
afraid of what is their visible goal
that they're going after and we're
structurally does the scene occur
because depending on how far along in
that inner journey the character is
that's going to affect how they would
react in a situation after you figured
those things out then the next question
you want to ask is what does my
character want in this scene and does
that desire is that desire going toward
ooh they think it's going to move them
closer to their goal or at least
overcome an obstacle to achieving their
goal if the answer to that question is
no then the scene should be jettisoned
it's not serving the story because every
scene has to move the character closer
to their visible goal or force them to
face an obstacle or anticipate an
obstacle that they didn't know they were
going to previously so let's say the
answer is yes though you do know that
this is going to contribute to the goal
and you figure out what do they want to
accomplish within the scene what do they
where do they want to be or what do they
want to have happen to the end of the
scene then what are they going to do to
try and do that that will constitute the
action of the scene the dialogue you
just set aside until all these other
things are figured out because the
dialogue is only really to reveal in
some way how they're feeling about the
situation or its dialogue where they're
trying to persuade somebody to do
something or get above somebody else
take control of a situation and so on
but first you want to see what does the
character want in the scene and then
what is the obstacle they must face in
the scene to achieving that because the
motion of a movie and the emotion of any
scene is primarily going to grow out of
the conflict if it's not the conflict
being faced right then it's the conflict
that they are anticipating or
occasionally that the audience is
anticipating and the thriller we may
know that the killer is in the next room
and all the hero wants to do is get to
the kitchen to make a sandwich but it's
still it's still about what do they want
and what are we anticipating is going
get in their way and then when it comes
to dialogue especially if you struggle
with dialogue get get something down you
should get anything down to begin with
just so you've got a scene to work with
rather than a blank page but if you
don't know what the dialogue should be
write dialogue where the character is
just saying how they feel and what they
want it's what's known as on-the-nose
dialogue it's terrible dialogue but at
least now you've got a scene
you've got action you've got character
you got dialogue and now you can ask the
last question there would be my
suggestion and that is okay now I know
what they want they're going through
this action how can I make it more
difficult for them first of all but also
instead of having them announce their
feelings or desires can they do it
without saying anything or if they in a
conversation how can they hide their
true desires or feelings and cover it up
with more surface superficial subtextual
language and that's sort of what you're
going for
and those are sort of the beats of going
through it then it's a matter of just
going through that process again and
again and again with each successive
draft but that will that will get you to
something if you're looking at a blank
page to begin with I find endings to be
easy I do they tell it tells me the
story tells me how it wants to end the
characters tell me what needs to happen
I think the hardest part for me is the
middle is like you know creating you
know a situation that has real conflict
and real confusion and real stuff to
work through that's not that's not just
cute or convenient for for a script
I almost always know the endings of
every one of these movies before we even
set down the road to you know to start
breaking it breaking it out point by
point I mean I knew the ending of
starlit I knew the ending of tangerine I
know the ending of the next film so
that's because I just I think endings
are very important to me
prints the same goes for prints of
Broadway and take-out so with all of
them I knew the ending was almost more
important in the beginning this is the
first time I'm thinking about this sort
of stuff so so I haven't been asked
these questions before so but ya know I
think it's actually I focused more on
the last scene and the impact the last
scene will have that's almost one of the
first things I think about you know with
tangerine it was the only thing we
thought about when I went to you know to
start our research process Chris bruh
gosh and I went to the corner of Santa
Monica and Highland we started
introducing ourselves to people etc you
know just telling them what we're going
to do when we finally found my aunt Kiki
I said I only have like a few ideas here
and one of them is well first off it has
to take place on one day because we have
a limited budget and costume changes
cost money and continuity cost money
it's easier to shoot in a ton of the
film that takes place in a 24 hour
period time the second one is that I
think people are coming together or
someone's trying to find somebody else
or whether that's a love story or a
revenge story I don't know and the third
is this ending I know I can see the
ending I can see all my characters
converging at the end at donut time in a
big climactic scene those were the only
things I saw going into it so it's funny
say thank you bring that up the endings
are very important to me because it's
about how the audience leaves the
theaters you know III think very much so
about the impact of that last scene if
you think I look at my favorite films
and my favorite films are like Harold
and Maude and when he's walking away at
the end after you know the the car goes
over the clip and you think he might be
in it but then he's up on the cliff and
he's with his banjo you have you know
something most of my favorite films have
such incredibly memorable lasting scenes
that have an impact on the audience as
they're sitting there during the final
credits and I think that that's
something I'm always conscious of it
says it's the most important thing for
me in a screenplay